you guys so today in my video I am going
to show you some of the worst phone
cases that I've ever seen in my entire
life and some of these are just out of
control I mean they're so funny that I
can't wait to show them to you and see
what you think before we get into those
a huge thank you to today's video
partner Dropbox who is sponsoring a
portion of this video Dropbox backup
super easy to use and it lets me have
access to all of my files when I'm on
the go I can back up my entire computer
and my external drives without worrying
about storage limits I like that I could
automatically have it upload with my
computers online and a drive is
connected and I won't have to worry
about a drive failing or something
tragic happening to my computer Dropbox
backup gives me the peace of mind that
all of my files are easily accessible
and safe this makes me feel so much more
at ease because I have so much valuable
content that I can never get back if
something were to happen to my external
drive but if something were to happen I
know that I can quickly recover my files
and be back up and running in no time if
you guys are interested in checking this
out head to dropbox.com iJustine to
choose your backup solution and start
backing up your life today a huge thank
you again to Dropbox for sponsoring a
portion of this video now my friends
let's get into unboxing all of these
cases
it's amazing some of them I actually
thought they looked kind of nice online
and then when I got them this is so
flimsy like what is this a carrot a
banana what is even in here I don't know
but we're about to find out not even
sure where to start or how to even kind
of go about this so maybe I will just
push these all to the side some of these
also were supposed to be for the iPhone
13 Pro Max and they definitely did not
ship iPhone 13. look at what is this
packaging I mean this looks like
something that I pick up my dog's turds
with when we go for a walk that's your
packaging first thing first let's see
what we have in here oh oh look at this
is very shiny very shimmery not so
splendid
okay wow well this is nice it actually
came with a glass screen protector as
well what a freaking treat do not use if
seal is broken well seal has been broken
it seems as though somebody has already
got their little mitts on this already
so you know I use a seals broken
what am I supposed to do
it was broken this even came with some
little gem Replacements because pretty
sure those rhinestones are not gonna
last okay let's put it on the phone and
see what it looks like I'm wondering how
many of these cases am I gonna get stuck
on my phone I'm gonna be very like this
that barely fits oh my god oh geez so
this is all kind of like a very um nice
look this is plasticky oh that's a sexy
right there
huh I mean from far away it looks cute
right
okay well I think we've seen enough uh
we have a lot more to go so one down I
have no idea how many are here but
there's a lot okay let's get this out of
here you you don't want to be here
do you look at this little number this
is like a shiny portfolio case
okay this just opens up it's magnetic
very fashionable very oh look at this it
even goes a little
string here oh I can put credit cards in
here wow there it is
looks great well I think we've seen
enough of that oh no I've ripped oh it
already already broke it I tried to get
it out and the whole case just ripped
off of here wow we wonder what the
return policy is on some of this garbage
because that's that's something look at
this one just a nice little mirrored
rhinestone Beauty like the quality could
not be better I'm basically twisting and
turning this thing oh that's not even
gonna fit on here so this is definitely
an iPhone 13. these literally all said
Pro Max so I don't know where the
disconnect is it's hard to say these are
such a terrible fit this doesn't even
fit in there can we just maybe stop for
a minute and just think about the
mistakes that you've made in life this
isn't even for the iPhone 13. look at
that
mistakes were made look no offense if
this is like your case company but do
better you don't list it as an iPhone 13
Pro Max and then it doesn't even fit on
the iPhone 13 Pro I don't
know all right so this one probably
won't protect you from any drops it kind
of looks cool you know like a little
something like that yeah this is this is
not too look at them it is what it is
okay this is actually kind of cute like
little bears a little chocolate chip
cookie this has
this one it's actually not that bad it
has a cute little lanyard and a little
cute little cookie keychain like get out
of here and this is like a soft little
fabric some of these are terrible but
this one is freaking cute so come at me
okay it's hard to push the buttons but
that is to be expected I suppose it
doesn't really fit very well I don't
think that I would trust this to hold my
phone up but this does have a really
cute little cookie keychain so that's
something this is very very cute I
actually love this a lot quality not the
best but the cute Factor super cute
interesting I don't know if this is
if this is a character that I'm supposed
to know is this like an nft is this what
is this day by day two loss to be found
hello world let me out uh okay I don't
think this is probably NASA approved but
it could be is that like NASA's like
character I die I don't know it's in
there but like it's not
it's barely in there this also looks
like it's kind of covering up the camera
lenses okay all of the lenses no see
look you can see the uh there's like a
ring around the wide angle so that's not
ideal you know if you actually want to
take pictures with a wide angle lens
you're gonna have like this ring around
it from the iPhone case this is terrible
this is just a disgrace clearly not
tested properly oh look at this little
number thank you for choosing our
products like the reason that I don't
even have merch is because some of the
merch companies that make things are so
trashy that I could not even physically
bring myself to sell them to you because
they're garbage quality
this is even for iPhone 13 no you're not
going to fit in there oh goodness
oh this is actually okay so I kind of
made fun of this one a little bit this
one's not so bad it actually feels like
a decent quality like this is
substantial like if I dropped it it
feels as though you know it might be
able to sustain camera bumps are all
exposed so we have to worry about any
lens issues and I actually like this
little ring right here that pops up so
you can use that it's like a pop socket
but like a knot socket it's like a piece
of jewelry so far this one is pretty
cool I like it I don't know where I'm
supposed to stick this oh right here on
the side that's nice oh whoa this is
another cool one this is the cam Shield
armor case this actually looks pretty
cool
you've got a full-on armored protection
which doesn't really
feel oh my God what is this it was even
as like a little camera lens protector
quality doesn't feel
so good so this has like this little
ring here and this little slidey to hide
our lenses that's actually kind of a
good idea because I feel like having
them protected it's not a bad
thought about thought I think you guys
got something here I mean the overall
quality is it's fine it's definitely not
the best but of all of the ones that
I've seen so far I do feel like this is
going to protect your phone and your
lens is the best not too bad what it is
okay iPhone 13 Pro so I have a feeling
this is not going to be another one
that's going to fit on the max
oh this is look at that have a good day
this is so I mean what is this is this
like a little holographic do I put this
on do I keep that in there I think I
keep that in there oh my God this is
absolutely just just garbage oh there's
a screen protector oh my God this came
with a screen protector this I don't
even know if that's gonna do anything
all right look at that good day like I'm
making fun of it because yeah this is
absolutely disgusting and hideous but
this is functional interesting
I'm making fun of it but yet I like this
idea like I could just be like I could
like pick up my drink
this is not a beer this is water just
non-sparkling basic water I can drink my
beer looking water with this iPhone case
so that's definitely something but God
this is the worst
quality I've ever seen in my life of
something okay interesting packaging
Choice uh-huh
some hearts some gold that's nice
quality uh pretty flimsy I like that
they've added some little extra
decorations here on the side like that's
nice really a beautiful Added Touch now
let's see what it looks like with the
gold phone in there definitely fits I
actually kind of like it like I don't I
don't hate it I mean I don't know if I
love it but I don't hate it this is a
nice little raised accent I guess that's
what we're gonna call it oh my God we
have so many more to go if you thought
we were almost done they're absolutely
not done
this is a beautiful Crystal number look
at this I mean if you can just see just
what I see I don't know see how it looks
on the phone maybe it'll have a better
look it's heavy this made my phone like
a freaking brick I can't even believe it
it's also really sharp like if you hit
somebody with this like that's going to
probably puncture their skin with these
little plastic fake diamonds uh quality
wise I don't know how long before one of
these falls off I have like one drop of
this it's probably gonna shatter but
here it is oh look at this I got this
one for Easter even though Easter's over
I thought it would be like a real
festive little bunny little case I don't
know how I feel about it it's very
unique I like that it has this added
little charm I like that it completely
changes the shape of your phone into a
weird carrot I like that it says ip13
Pro Max so you know if you know you know
let's hope this actually fits in here
because I think this might be my new
iPhone case for the for the rest of the
term can you just like can you take me
seriously doing a business call trying
to close
um the series a round hi yeah sure we
would love to accept our funding I would
love that I love that for us and our
company oh my God I love it it's so
stupid it's so stupid but it might be
the most perfect thing I've ever seen
oh so freaking good check this out it's
like a little camera
a little camera strap oh this is cool
obviously equality is not uh super high
you know kind of looking at it from afar
you can't tell it's gonna probably pop
right off just like that you can't tell
that can you well maybe you can I like
this has like a fake little Mount here I
mean you might be able to actually mount
something there which would be kind of
cool these buttons don't really work
this could potentially could be
um like a good weapon though because
that's pretty pretty substantial so you
might want to think about that guess
these just hook here in these Corner
little areas interesting uh-huh
foreign
so I like how this looks though because
this actually does look really really
nice but again like the the actual build
quality pretty subpar
I am struggling to get my phone out of a
lot of these cases and it's not it's not
nice it definitely cracked my front
screen it is what it is guess that's the
price of doing business God these are so
over there with so many okay this next
one I'm very excited about my favorite
fruit is bananas so when I saw that
there was a banana iPhone case you
better believe I freaking had to have it
oh my God this is God it smells so bad
this is this is the most repulsive thing
that I've ever seen absolutely this is
repulsive I am disgusted by the look of
this I'm disgusted by the feel
try not to throw up
oh my God the feeling is so disgusting I
I can't stand it I don't think I've ever
hated something so much oh my God the
smell the texture of it
like
[Music]
what
somebody came up with this idea there
was more than one person that agreed
that this would be a good idea of
something to make this is this was a
concept and then it came to fruition and
here we are this does look like a real
banana though I will say that
oh my God I hate it I
I have to go wash my hands I'm so
disgusted I can't I can't I can't I have
to wash my hands
my hands are washed and I have to take
my phone out of this case I hate
everything about it I gotta get my phone
out of here I'm so disgusted like I wash
my hands and now I like sex punched it
again and I can't even this can't I have
to just uh oh okay that you're fired
look at this this is the most garbage
presentation of packaging that I've ever
seen like now I'm just getting I'm
getting mad because I actually spent
real money on this stuff everything
about this you should be ashamed of
yourself what in the world is this what
does what is this what is the service of
this purpose
what is the purpose of the service
designed for you no slide bumper do I
put a credit card in there that means
nothing to me I don't understand what
that means and clearly I wouldn't know
because there's no directions or
anything that came with this so I don't
know anything about it what is your
purpose my friend I don't even know if I
care what your purpose is at this point
because you're not cool does this does
this come on okay well what does that
mean
what does that mean I don't get it oh
look at this one game phone case okay
now we're talking my language this is
very cute
um this sticker helps to remove the mask
for the screen guard look at that that's
so cute like it actually looks like it
might do something oh my God I think it
actually does oh no way wait I can
charge this off okay well something
something happens here so this is this
is special we are in freaking business
now
oh my God okay it's charging it's
charging oh oh my God there's freaking
games on here in here get out of here oh
my God there's freaking Tetris what the
heck I'm literally freaking playing
Tetris okay I did a bad job
what a freaking deal I mean I thought
that I was getting an iPhone case but
little did we know we were getting whole
console I can still smell the banana
phone case and it's making me want to
throw up can you believe this iPhone
case but also a freaking tiny little
mini console I can play Nintendo games
on here what is happening how are you
real oh this is the coolest thing ever
I'm gonna charge this case up and I'm
gonna use it I'm gonna impress all of my
friends
oh look at this little number wow looks
like a little purse
wallet combo Beauty fashion love to see
it it's got a nice little wallet here oh
boy love the quality this is probably on
par with the other one that I tried out
like in the beginning that kind of fell
apart I think it could be possibly like
the same exact thing these are so poorly
made don't even know how to feel about
it granted these are very inexpensive so
like if you are just looking for like I
don't know a very inexpensive case like
these are gonna do the trick here's the
thing if you are okay this actually
would protect it I feel like like this
doesn't look that bad at all like when
you're looking at it like this
kind of looks cute I'm like hating on
these but like some of them I think you
can get by functional utility you're
literally paying for what you're getting
which is not a high quality product but
hey it's it's gonna get the job done
[Applause]
this is interesting kind of like the
holographic little look to it okay
they're protecting you from scratching
your phone right there with these very
hard uh metal little pieces I don't know
what to say about it really is this a
character that I don't know about is
this from something it looks like this
has some little puffy paint glitter that
somebody just kind of you know outlined
this with I love the iridescence uh it
looks like this also kind of comes off
slides up so you can put your hand in it
so that's kind of nice I'm trying to be
positive I feel as though I've been very
negative but it's really I
it's very easy to be I do like that this
seamlessly covers the iPhone lenses like
it still keeps them exposed so this is
actually a pretty good fit so all things
considered like yeah quality pretty low
oh this text is absolutely hideous as
far as like the actual fit of being on
this thing like they did a pretty good
job I also kind of like this little hand
holding case very cheaply made they
definitely got all the dimensions
correct you guys we still have a lot
more to go what in the world is this
look I have no idea
why is this so long
okay so looks like somebody has found
their forever iPhone case this is
absolutely the most incredible thing
that I've ever seen in my whole life
looks like somebody has already touched
it and slimed it up with their little
fingers you can see that that's that's
definitely been handled uh yeah there's
fingerprints on that that's disgusting
oh my god oh I'm so disgusted okay we're
just gonna go like that yeah that's
slimy oh God just I feel like I need to
scrub my whole body now why is
everything so gross oh man I don't think
it's gonna fit in here
just when I thought oh no it's fitting
I'm making it we're making it it's okay
it fit what who who thought this was a
good idea to put this tassel on here why
would you do that
oh
my God I can't wait to show this to my
sister I'm just gonna go up to her and
be like hey can I take a picture of you
this is
the case and it's a knife it's like a
hatchet I have like tears in my eyes I'm
laughing so hard oh my God it's
incredible will this even fit in the
vertical frame that I've been doing
this is the world that we live in okay
what's this this looks like a knockoff
Disney Mickey ears color foot eye phone
13. oh whoa what is that a weird little
thing so these are like those kids
little fidget popper things that like my
little niece has she's like been playing
with since she was like one I'd like
that it gives you that added little
bonus of this little keychain like very
nice so the problem is they don't pop
down when you have the case on it that's
sad if you planned on popping this and
having a little fidget popper it does
not pop I mean I guess from far away
look it kind of looks cool I kind of
like this one I mean it definitely
doesn't serve the purpose of being able
to kind of fidget pop but I like the
colors game this is
super basic look I don't think you can
get any more basic
oh it smells so rancid oh my God so here
it is we've got a nice little heart
plastic thing here I mean this kind of
looks like something I would eat a
lavender candy bar maybe but no it is an
iPhone case let's see how the camera
looks so if you do use the wide angle
there is a little gradient around the
corners so definitely not functional if
you're going to be taking photos with it
but there it is
everybody so this one actually looks
kind of nice
this is one of my favorite colors other
than pink look at this we got some
little stickers with this too for
covering your private shipping
information on the package tear off and
paste huh I feel like this might be the
most I guess normal one of the bunch so
I can't even say that I hate this
because this is one of my favorite
colors it actually seems to fit pretty
well I can push the buttons there's no
branding and it's just overall like the
most decent simple case that I feel like
anybody could ever ask for I mean if
you'd like the color this is going to be
a great case so far so good but is it
magsafe compatible
um it is not we have a few more what is
this beautiful baby pink can you up oh
boy wow like is this supposed to be like
a Barbie kind of inspired phone but not
Barbie I guess
um branded because it's clearly from
some sort of knockoff company can you up
Barbie's not gonna say that I mean maybe
she might but like no hey Ken you up if
I roll my eyes any harder they're gonna
fall out of my head oh look at this
little little bear beautiful
the bear Pro Max
also has a baby bear oh that's so cute
so some of these are you know not that
terrible I think we saw a few wins today
like come on now baby bear Big Bear this
is overall increased the size of my
iPhone by at least one and a half so
it's basically doubled it like this is
absolutely just massive look at this
bear it is very very cute though I will
say that all right we've got
two more that look very similar
yeah these both look very much alike I
don't know if these are going to fit on
here this might be an iPhone
13. yes it is that just seems the way
that it has worked out I kind of
actually like this it made it like super
square and boxy which is kind of neat
and this one has a magnetic bracket oh
you can make it into a little kickstand
like look at that interesting
let's first take a look at this one I
like the little heart is right there in
the center where the Apple logo would be
I love the gold around the edges it does
look like this could have some sort of
little string so you could have a little
attachment I really like around the
corners is they're kind of like this
Jagged Little Edge that looks cool it
made it kind of like a real pointy
little feature very boxy quality
obviously not that great kind of looks
pretty cool then this one looks very
similar but it does have the rounded
edges and this has like a little
kickstand like check this out that's
cool look at this
I mean quality again not that great but
like I can still use my phone like this
I don't even have to touch it I mean
it's not really that sturdy so if I do
push it a little too much it's gonna
fall over but I do like that this has a
little added kickstand to it I also
really like the White and the gold
combination it's very pretty well
friends
um
this is all the cases we opened up today
and there's a lot of them this banana
one still is so rancid like the smell of
it is making me absolutely physically
nauseous like I feel physically ill I
don't like it I saw a lot of things
today I don't know how I feel I don't
know how you feel but I now have a bunch
of cases that I don't know what to do
with
yeah this is so oh God it's such a
smelly banana
um I'll see you guys in the next video I
gotta go I gotta wash my hands I need to
go shower like I feel
so gross so okay I'm done we're done
here I gotta go I gotta go
[Music]